deswegen war ich will einfach weiter
lasst mich einmal rein bitte hey was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen bio hier aus prag oder nicht fragt
wunderbar vor ort lassen
wir sehen ja eigentlich viel erfahren
also ich habe heute einige gäste gerade
sind hier dabei nathan marica und annika
kann sein dass gleich noch jemand
dazukommt
schauen wir mal auf jeden fall haben wir
uns jetzt gedacht wir fangen auf jeden
fall mal an ich weiß nicht ihr könnt
euch nicht vorstellen oder nein
außerdem ist es sich auf zehn minuten
strecken das wird bei mir gibt es fast
kein video unter zehn übrigens auch kein
thema so partie könnte die werden ja gar
nicht mal also ich schneide das immer
noch unter das ist genau zehn minuten
kommen wir zum thema also wir sind in
tschechien prag ist die hauptstadt von
tschechien und ich war vorgestern im
titel hier und in bilder hieß es und
tankstelle also bei 35 und habe wirklich
lange gesucht und habe insgesamt zehn
verschiedene tschechische süßigkeiten
gekauft wobei ich mir bei 2 nicht sicher
bin ob sie wirklich nur ob das
tschechische sagen aber ich hab mich
geguckt und ich habe nichts gesehen was
ich in deutschland schon mal des jahres
definitiv sagt wir nicht kennen so dass
das jemand das einzige wo ich mir
unsicher ob das vielleicht auch in
deutschland gibt
die nada ist also die marke besteht hier
auch deswegen ich würde sagen ihr dürft
abwechselnd immer eingreifen oder aber
dass du das anfangen
[Musik]
also haben wir unicode in ascii sollte
man das macht
ich hab zwar genommen 23 manchmal
richtig scheiße ich manchmal einfach
sagen irgendwann die idee es gibt jetzt
zu machen aber wusste nicht wie es gut
funktioniert
ich finde es eigentlich in ordnung ich
habe es nicht so gut
ich glaube ich habe meine wahl der
pekings unten im grünen nicht auf die
mischung war scheiße ich das hier sind
runic das ist wohl so dass tschechien
also das ist sehr beliebt hier
ich habe gegoogelt und das ist das was
die direkt angezeigt
das gibt es in drei verschiedenen sorten
wir haben noch gut mit joghurt
anscheinend und mit vanille und machten
erst mal auf
wir haben oder also ich habe mal
probieren sich dann ganz oben ist so
irgendwas cremiges und unten ist
irgendwas schokoladige gar nicht banane
banana ja mal probieren
von alex das was wir uns auch nicht so
gut nur dass mit der show ist gut aber
ich hatte auch nicht diese komische zeug
kaufen was das denn das ist schokolade
mit nüssen schokolade möchte ich
eigentlich am krassesten und zwar so
eine richtige eclipse help hat man muss
sein aussehen ist auf jeden fall ein
zehntel der aussendung weiter
jeder der daran vorbeigeht denkst du
auch nicht mal probieren
marin musste die unbedingt schon auf
deswegen greift nun mal rein
dieser meldete da machen sein wenn ich
kann euch den geschmack zu 100 prozent
beschreiben
aber jeder von euch hat doch schon mal
im freibad dieses komponisten gestern
mit diesem komischen dieser kuchen
schmeckt genauso wenn es jetzt in
deutschland gehen würde würde ich hier
auf kleinsten also die gut mal die sich
jetzt richtig gehen man kann ich die
schule aber nicht auf dauer eine ganze
packung nun wirklich alles gut
da schenke ich dir das hier genau kubik
das ist auf jeden fall glaube ich auch
was ist ein geschützter hexe wobei das
gibt es auch in deutschland ist die baby
kekse werden die koalas ich glaube die
leute und auch in deutschland und somit
ihr sonntag ist ja mit wissenschaftlich
marktkauf die weiß wie man sich trotz
blitz ja ja ja diese
coco akzeptiert wenn ich jetzt auch
nicht so heißt das ist eigentlich das
was ich gar nicht einordnen kann und
zwar was glaubt ihr ist dass das ist
nämlich man nicht so dass es
wahrscheinlich ziemlich leicht aber es
ist schwer das ist
dieser ist dass man immer aber ich hätte
gedacht dass das ist aber es ist nicht
das ist nicht wenig darf eine monstranz
oder protein ist das oder ich glaube das
was meinst aber dann wäre es leichter
habe ich auch gedacht boote waren worden
das macht man sowas plastik lassen da
man schimpfen gibt keine gesetze die
verbieten
[Musik]
es ist nicht mal das
ich will das nicht erstens einmal das
riecht wie plastik ich fand das ist
allerdings dass vorher google und das
wirklich zum helden machen
[Musik]
das ist das richtige kleber wie ich die
körper riecht wie käse schnitt das war
schwere es was ist das denn kunst die
sie konnten das ist so giftig dass so
ein netter schmeckt sorry aber es
schmeckt wie sie kurzzeitig sekunden
lasst mich einmal rein wolfs bitte ich
glaube ich brauche diese teile außen
herum
die sonne habe das auto im feld haben
sowas macht zu kommen
das ist doch nicht ist es sicher zum
essen wenn google damals geholt und das
wird nicht mehr teams hier schon
schmecken
das schmeckt ja aber alle schmecken
probier mal also das ist so krass
einfach direkt rein weiß es ist so kann
[Musik]
ich muss mein größter ein bisschen müde
aber es kommt fast gleich das schmeckt
kriege ich mal treffen
es soll eigentlich zum essen was ich
will jetzt auch nicht brach also
technisch schlecht geben so aber was
hätten sie vor das war richtig
merkwürdig das war richtig was zu messen
immerhin bestimmt so suggeriert stärken
oder ja wenn er diese ich bin gespannt
auf die sind ja machen
zum spaß außerdem ist eine sache wenn
nicht unbedingt das möchte unbedingt
heute gefordert
aber es wieder sagt leber aber diesmal
ist es die ja ich will dich mal ab weil
ein
ich wünsche euch viel spaß danke sagen
haben wir noch kein problem
gut das ist fest leute ich glaube das
war es auch schon ich war auf jeden fall
statt ein ländern mit besseren
süßigkeiten was aber ich finds echt froh
als das volk und ja es gibt echt kannst
du lachen
also wenn wir das jetzt jemand man würde
das nicht als essen identifizieren wenn
man ganz klar besser an lasst doch nach
oben da alle kanäle sind natürlich in
der beschreibung verlinkt und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder um 19 uhr gibt's neues
video hat tragen ja klar sei jemand das
bei dir